alright that same prosecutor saying the
Smollett paid two brothers to stage this
attack they even rehearsed it with a
check paid with a check kind of like
Jerry Springer pretty brilliant now
phone records show the actor called them
before and immediately after the
incident another brilliant move and Tex
show the trio coordinating the alleged
hoax other texts revealing that one of
the brothers even sold designer drugs to
small it and police are now saying that
small likely scratched his own face to
make the attack more believable by the
way that kind of takes hating Trump
psychosis to a whole new level all
occurring of course after small it
allegedly send himself a threatening
racist letter containing a white powdery
substance another genius move we have
forensics now if this is all truth this
turns out to be truth nothing funny
about it small it wasted precious law
enforcement resources in a city that has
been wracked with real violent crime for
many many years now a city where young
people and even women or children are
shot people are murdered every single
week in Chicago lots of them it's also
appears that he used his celebrity
status and raised to smear and slander
the people of Chicago Trump supporters
everywhere and according to police he
did it for attention sympathy and
because he was unhappy with his
seven-figure salary the judge called
these alleged actions despicable the
Chicago Police Superintendent Eddie
Johnson's his name rightly outraged this
was one of the single most powerful
press conferences I have ever watched
take a look this announcement today
recognizes that Empire actor justice
Millette
took advantage of the pain and anger of
racism to promote his career why would
anyone especially an african-american
man use the symbolism of a noose to make
false accusations how could someone look
at the hatred and suffering associated
with that symbol and see an opportunity
to manipulate that symbol to further his
own public profile bogus police reports
calls real harm they do harm to every
legitimate victim who's in need of
support by police and and investigators
as well as the citizens of this city I
was a powerful press conference by the
police superintendent now it was just
one week ago that Smollett what a Good
Morning America for an interview with
Robin Roberts this is what he said to
her let's take a look how can you doubt
that like how do you how do you not
believe that it's the truth and then it
became a thing of like oh it's not
necessarily that you don't believe that
this is the truth you don't even want to
see the truth it feels like if I had
said it was a Muslim or Mexican or
someone black I feel like the doubters
would have supported me a lot much more
a lot more and that says a lot about the
place that we are in our country right
now I respect too much the people who I
am now one of those people who have been
attacked in any way you do such a
disservice when you lie about things
like this
Joseph Smollett is no longer speaking
with the media although there are
reports tonight that he is back on the
set of Empire his lawyer stated that
they are planning a quote aggressive
defense and they asked that their client
be given the presumption of innocence
even though small it didn't afford the
same noble principle to justice
Cavanaugh just a few months ago he
tweeted out hashtag oh I believe dr.
Christine Blasi Ford and much worse
still on this show in spite of these
unfolding events we recognize that being
innocent presumed innocent until proven
guilty it is and in a Lea belite even
afforded to those with no principles and
in this particular case the evidence is
beginning to look overwhelming and
incontrovertible none of it good for mr.
Smollett now I remember back a while ago
I said the same thing about Michael
avenatti I'm sure doesn't agree with
much of what I say remember his case but
that was a he said/she said
in the end I kept saying I will give him
the due process and presumption of
innocence that he never gave judge
Cavanaugh there were three separate
investigations and he got cleared in
other words they cleared him of any
wrongdoing now despite the massive
amount of evidence against the Empire
actor you have to assume he's an
innocent man until convicted in a court
of law
so that is standard for anybody but
tonight this is about so much more than
an overpaid attention-seeking wanting a
raise Trump aiding actor the Smollett
case represents another example of what
I have been saying since oh seven and oh
eight journalism in this country is dead
in case after case after case the
mainstream media they devour you know
any story that just fits their radical
extreme extension of the Democratic
Socialist Party agenda if it advances
the narrative that Donald Trump is evil
and his supporters are bad and America
is scary and racist and sexist
homophobic xenophobic Islamophobic the
media mob will shift into full gear
without performing any due diligence
without even picking up the telephone
without any kind of investigation not
even five minutes worth look at what
they did to this 16 year old coming in
high school student and of a 15 second
blurb they accused him of being a racist
they went out they harassed him accused
him of assaulting a 65 year old activist
and getting in his face they tried to
ruin this kid's life slander smearing
besmirching character assassination they
accused justice Cavanaugh of gang rape
every other weekend they he and his
friends were drugging teenage girls and
literally you know lining up in the hall
for these gang rapes that nobody ever
reported and of course they tried to
ruin his life trying to call him an
alcoholic we know how that ended he's
now a Supreme Court justice
remember they falsely accused UVA
students of rape remember the Duke
lacrosse players accused them of rape 80
some odd professors at Duke bought the
story hook line and sinker without any
evidence and it turns out I actually
went to meet some of the family members
some of the kids doing my own due
diligence now they falsely accused
Darren Wilson remember me used to be a
police officer his career is over George
Zimmerman everybody was saying he was
guilty but there was an eyewitness that
showed up several police in Baltimore
everybody was assured they're gonna get
guilty pleas none of them did and guess
what as we speak they're falsely
accusing President Trump of Russia
collusion that too is a hoax while
simultaneously ignoring what is now a
mountain of evidence of the single
biggest abuse of power corruption
scandal in history where they tried to
rig an election and then undo an
election a duly elected president of the
United States in the era a Trump
far-left hoaxes way too common the media
way too complicit but they buy these
stories again and again hook line sinker
vilifying innocent people in the process
over and over again when the stories are
exposed when the lies are revealed
so-called journalists at so-called news
organizations they move on they just
pretend like it never happened
oh like NBC News they were talking all
about this so this started happening I
were all over the Jesse Smollett story
look the hills joe Concha monitored all
of MSNBC conspiracy TV's primetime shows
they totally ignored the charges against
Smollett now after they were pushing the
hate crime narrator for weeks and weeks
they just that now like it never
happened NBC News prominent Democrats
they employ the same tactic far left
presidential frontrunner Kamala Harris
just like Cory Booker calling the
smollett incident a modern day lynching
today after a meeting with the Reverend
Al Sharpton she totally ignored any
questions about Smollett
take a listen
for the party we might we might judge
you small did you jump into this smoking
gun defense too early smaller now
senator Harris has since put out a
statement saying that she said all while
taking a veil shot of course the
President Trump that never stops
meanwhile fake news cNN has just
discovered something called due process
and now urging all of us not to rush to
judgment which is a joke this after
running wild with speculation about the
so-called smollett attack interesting
timing take a look this is a Jackie
Robinson against homophobia in the black
community an icon a beloved icon and now
you have the fall of an icon at a time
when we need icons when we need heroes
when we need people as who stand up so
the level of betrayal if this is true
yes it's so deep you can see it in your
voice you can see it in your face it's
almost hard to get the words out because
of how beloved he has been we still
don't know everything and I don't want
to see us rush to judgment on this side
rush to judgment on that side condemn
this condemn that that's the part of the
thing we've been talking about is that
we're now in the cycle where everybody
that have an instant complete opinion
every 15 seconds yeah I don't want to do
that that's the same guy that said on
election night this is a white lash well
you should tell that to all of his
colleagues who are constantly pushing
fake news so long as it fits their hate
Trump mob mentality media listen to
radio talk-show host Rush Limbaugh today
he summarized the state of the media
pitch-perfect take a look the left is
nothing but phony hate crimes phony
alleged hate crimes phony charges made
of stories they know these things
probably aren't true but they want them
to be and that's why they report them is
true they think this is what America is
in the mind of the American left these
crimes are happening everywhere even if
the smullin case isn't real
it's real elsewhere and we must raise
consciousness the media is signing onto
it the celebrities are signing out
presidential candidates are signing onto
it and tweeting what a rotten place
America is because of it now Russia is
right the mobs disgusting bias it is
obvious both from what they obsess over
and what they choose to sweep under the
rug for example on Tuesday pro Trump
activists recruiting students for the
conservative group Turning Point USA was
violently assaulted at UC Berkeley
watch this
[Applause]
now to be consistent affair we don't
know what occurred before that video but
what we do know is that police are
currently looking for the person you
just saw throwing the punches and the
person that was punched well tonight
tell his story will reserve judgment the
individual assaulted will join us later
in the show we're looking for the truth
but you won't likely see him on Good
Morning America getting a friendly
interview from Robin Roberts or any
other mainstream media outlet for that
matter this alleged assault potential
political hate crime doesn't fit their
narrative journalism dead and buried